hello everyone and welcome to today's
live presentation biomarkers to
discriminate bacterial and viral
infections presented by Ephraim Sonic MD
PhD associate professor of medicine
department of molecular genetics and
microbiology Duke University School of
Medicine I am Christina mahalik of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's events we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone but
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do this
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box that appears on the screen will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation now
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem additionally this presentation
is educational and most offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continue continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now please join me in welcoming
dr. Salik I will now turn the
presentation over to him dr. Salik the
floor is yours
great thank you so much and thank you
all for joining today and what I'd like
to tell you about today is a little bit
of where things stand in the
discrimination of bacterial and viral
infections and in particular the role of
biomarkers to aid in that process so the
the context for this rests largely with
acute respiratory illness in the
reason is because acute respiratory
illness or a RI is the syndrome in which
bacterial and viral ideologies are most
most commonly present and the etiology
sport obviously things like meningitis
and encephalitis or gastrointestinal
illness can also have overlap with
respect to having the bacterial and
viral ideologies but acute respiratory
illnesses are by far the most prevalent
in the most common cause for patients to
seek care and the most common scenario
in which an inability to discriminate
bacterial and viral infections leads to
antibiotic overuse respiratory tract
infections caused more than 3 million
deaths globally and 164 million
disability-adjusted life years lost
annually and again that's also on a
global scale and the reason that I bring
that up is while most respiratory
illnesses are mild the common cold being
the most typical example respiratory
tract infections can also cause
significant morbidity and mortality and
so it leads to a lot of concern among
providers that they be treated
appropriately and if there's a choice
between under treating or over treating
the statistics would say that most
people end up getting over treated
specifically the majority of acute
respiratory illness is viral and yet up
to 75% of all ambulatory care visits end
with prescriptions for antibacterials so
we know that patients are getting
antibiotics inappropriately and that has
consequences
it increases antibiotic resistance and
that's become a significant concern with
a number of alarm sounding both
nationally as well as internationally it
increases costs of care in part for the
cost of the medication but also for the
management of adverse effects related to
those medications to those antibiotics
among patients presenting to emergency
rooms for drug-related side effects
antibiotics are the second most common
reason the first being anticoagulants
and so there are real harms that come
along with antibiotic use in particular
inappropriate
biotic usse there was a study that came
out now in 2015 although this group the
ethic consortium continues to put out
papers epic was a CDC sponsored study
that focused on the etiology of
pneumonia in the community this is a
multi-site study that that asked about
the microbiological etiology of
pneumonia and in order to do so they
employed some pretty extensive
microbiological phenotyping they
performed standard things like sputum
culture blood culture or antigen testing
but they also employed a lot of research
modalities for example serologies for a
variety of different pathogens PCR based
detection to really try and develop the
most comprehensive understanding of the
etiology of pneumonia among patients in
in the US and they had two papers and
I've pulled a couple of figures from
each of them one focused on adults and
one focused on children the notable
thing among adults is that despite that
extensive microbiological testing the
majority of patients 62% had no pathogen
identified but that doesn't mean that
they didn't have an infection but that
the infections were caused by pathogens
that we lacked the ability to identify
interestingly over the ones where
pathogens were identified the majority
were viral 22% of cases with pneumonia
only had a viral pathogen identified 2%
more had more than one virus identified
3% had a bacterial and viral pathogen an
identified and so only 11% of patients
with pneumonia had a bacterial pathogen
identified exclusively which is in
contrast the way that most people will
treat community-acquired pneumonia and
what we assume to be true of
community-acquired pneumonia that it is
by by far most commonly caused by
bacteria and other pathogens like
viruses and fungus causing a minority of
cases but this study shed some light on
that now of course it may be difficult
to know what that 62% is and those may
very well be bacterial pathogens then
our
techniques lack the ability to identify
it may also be the case that if
bacterial and pathogens are difficult to
identify that perhaps a lot of those
cases of viral pneumonia also had a
concurrent bacterial pathogen so there's
still a lot that's unknown and uncertain
about this in the pediatric population
we see a little bit of a different set
of findings particularly among the
youngest groups the rate at which
pathogens and the rate at which no
pathogen was identified was much lower
you can see in that group of children
less than two years old that it was just
over ten percent that white box at the
very top was the no pathogen identified
group and so in the majority of children
a pathogen is being identified and of
the pathogens that are being found most
of them are viral across all age groups
viral or more than one viral pathogen
was found in about two-thirds of cases
and in the youngest group that was over
approximately 80% of cases of viral at
least one viral pathogen must identify
and really and only a small number of
cases was a bacterial pathogen
identified or even a bacterial and viral
coda tection so it suggests that in
children pneumonia again the same
caveats apply in terms of our ability to
define to find all of the different
etiologic agents of pneumonia but
viruses seem to be playing a much more
prominent role among children with
pneumonia continuing on with this the
top figure here is the one I had just
showed you but to break it down in terms
of what the viruses are it does vary by
age group and in the oldest age group
that pie chart all the way on the right
10 to 17 year olds that tends to mimic
the types of pathogens that you see in
the adult population as well but in the
youngest groups you see RSV and Rhino
virus being the most commonly identified
metonym of iris is commonly identified
adenovirus pear influenza virus
influenza and then corona virus and then
strep pneumo sort of round outs of
groups and so the assumption of these
four
studies is that if we are trying to
differentiate between bacterial and
viral pathogens then finding the
pathogen must indicate what the nature
of the diseases and there are some
limitations with that not the least of
which is the fact that pathogen
identification strategies are of limited
sensitivity for example in the adult
version of the epic study the majority
of patients had no package identified
and so that makes it very difficult to
extrapolate whether or not those
patients have a bacterial pathogen that
might need antibiotics or a viral
pathogen that really won't benefit from
antibiotics and some of the different
approaches that one might take now to
get into some of the specific tests are
for example rapid antigen tests these
are some of the oldest tests that we've
had at our disposal these include things
like rapid strep rapid flu and just to
highlight some of the strengths and
limitations here I'll present to you the
rapid antigen test for influenza
typically these detect influenza A and
influenza B they don't subtype although
clinically it may not necessarily be
that important to subtype in terms of
determining whether or not to treat a
patient with Tamiflu for example the
nice thing is that they're fast they're
relatively affordable they're the
specificity is quite good 90 to 95
percent specific so if you have a
positive result it's one you can assume
is likely to be real but the sensitivity
is highly limited and in particular this
was most noteworthy in the 2009 h1n1
outbreak where the existing rapid
antigen tests were of such low
sensitivity that there were
recommendations against their use the
sensitivity continues to be quite
variable it's certainly improved and we
can see numbers in the US by 70% but it
still has some limitations the figure
that you see there in the middle of the
panel here indicates what the positive
and negative predictive values are and
really highlights the fact that that flu
testing particularly with an imperfect
test is highly dependent on where you
are in the season and so for example if
it's not in the midst of flu season and
you were to run a test even a positive
test does not have that good of a
positive predictive value Namie
and reaching 80% but if you are in flu
season a negative test result
particularly with these rapid antigen
tests does not by any means exclude the
possibility of influenza where you see
that that negative predictive value
dropping only as low as 80% in the midst
of a flu outbreak of a flu season and so
the table on the bottom again highlight
some of those numbers and compares the
different types of etiology testing for
influenza including rapid antigen
fluorescence antibodies and a
respiratory viral panel we'll talk about
some of those a little bit later on
again it highlights that sensitivity can
be quite poor the specificity is high
meaning if you get a positive result
it's a pretty useful test if you get a
negative result it can sometimes be a
meaningless test depending on that
particular test that you're using there
are newer generation rapid antigen test
for lewin for influenza and a couple of
them have been identified here one of
them is the BT Barrett or and the Cadell
Sophia in these cases the sensitivities
are a bit better
ranging anywhere from the 60s to the
high 80s specificities are also pretty
high in most cases greater than 95% and
this is true of both the the B D is a
little bit better in terms of
sensitivity than the liquid L but both
of these again offer relatively rapid
results reasonably affordable and are
generally conducive to use in a primary
care environment another rapid antigen
test example is RSV in this case I won't
go into the details but the numbers here
are very similar to what you see for
influenza again the to digital point of
care assays that that are identified
here or the the B D and the Cadell what
about Group a stret this is another one
that's very commonly used in a primary
care or an outpatient environment and
there was a meta-analysis of these
different in particular these different
platforms the solana the the Li op lab
in a tube the Sophia and the quick view
and those are the quid L products well
you can see here is that the pooled
sensitivity across all of these was 86
to 91 percent and the pooled specificity
was in the mid to high 90s so those are
again pretty good all things considered
it's still useful to think about the
pretest probability and and it times
people use the center or clinical
criteria in order to gauge the
likelihood that vets strep is present
and that's useful because if strep is
extremely unlikely to be present then a
positive result may end up being a false
positive
and if strep is extremely likely to be
present a negative result doesn't
necessarily exclude the existence and
disease so it's important to bear in
mind that performance characteristics of
these tests but again given these
sensitivities and specificities they
they can be quite useful particularly in
an outpatient environment and so other
pathogen identification approaches
beyond rapid antigen tests include
sputum culture and what I'll do is I'll
highlight one particular study here this
is a study of about 1,700 patients with
community acquired pneumonia and what
this the purpose of the study was to
determine both the frequency with which
sputum culture ultimately provided
useful information so of that group of
1,700 patients only a 59% of them were
actually able to provide any sputum
sample at all for analysis of those only
about half of them were considered of
good quality based on the presence of
neutrophils based on the absence of
epithelial cells of that group only
about a half of them had a quality and a
predominant Morpho type in terms of
bacterial cells that were identified on
Gram stain and then those ultimately
yielded a positive culture in 86 percent
of cases the yield and culture was only
twenty percent in cases that had a good
quality specimen but without a
predominant more code type
and so when you boil all that down
you find is that a good quality sputum
with a predominant Morpho type was only
present in about 14% of patients with
community of our pneumonia the
likelihood of getting a good quality
specimen was independent of pneumonia
severity and it really highlights the
fact that sputum culture is of use and
is is particularly helpful and it's
positive but it's going to be unlikely
to be helpful in the vast majority of
cases of community acquired pneumonia
then we've gotten urine antigen tests
and in particular these exist primarily
for Legionella as well as streptococcus
pneumoniae the urine antigen tests are
likewise relatively fast and simple to
perform a meta-analysis of 27 studies
focusing specifically on the bine acts
for the urinary strep pneumonia test and
what they did is they used culture as
the reference standard found that it
only had a 69% sensitivity and
specificity of 84% no this is a common
pattern where we see high specificity
and lower sensitivity again in this case
the sensitivity of 69% does not exclude
the existence of pneumococcal pneumonia
with a negative test but a specificity
of 84% also doesn't necessarily mean
that that if positive pneumococcal
streptococcus pneumoniae is the pathogen
and in particular children especially
those under 12 years of age are known to
have high rates of carriage and of
shedding with positive pneumococcal
antigen tests in the absence of symptoms
so specificity is particularly low in a
pediatric population and such that this
test is not usually performed in that
group the numbers for Legionella are a
bit higher particularly the specificity
and that's largely because there are low
rates of asymptomatic Harwich of
Legionella and in this case these
numbers were based on the meta-analysis
of 30 studies and they used six
different methods to assess those 32
different assays okay moving on from
urine antigen testing to Nath's which
nucleic acid amplification tests these
generally come in two flavors single
target or Posse analyte meaning that
they're really only targeting one or a
few pathogens and then multiplex panel
of which there are a variety of
different versions that are made some of
them are identified here the bio fire
Luminex Gen mark nanosphere are all
different examples of these things to
highlight here these are some of the FDA
cleared Nats that have targeted panels
meaning that they are either focusing on
one or just a few pathogens you can see
the different types of viruses that are
detected in these most of them focus on
flu beyond that RSV is often the next
one to be added on and then after that
there there are a handful that viruses
that are added on sensitivity and
specificity for these viruses are
generally quite good you see numbers for
both sensitivity and specificity that
are in the 90s and and reaching 100% in
some cases there are some exceptions to
that for example in the focus simplex
a-- their influenza B assay has
sensitivities that have been reported to
be a little bit on the low side but
quite a range up to 100 percent likewise
with the pro Desa the RSV is a little
bit lower but still at eighty nine point
five percent power influenza eighty nine
percent those are still pretty good
especially when you compare them to
antigen based tests so these nucleic
acid amplification tests many of which
can be fairly rapid do offer quite
significant improvements in sensitivity
and specificity over the antigen tests
among the multiplex panel here again or
for them identified in what you can see
here the distribution of different
pathogens that are targeted by these
many of the viruses are the same in
terms of the different panels influenza
A influenza B RSV parainfluenza virus
meta numa virus Rhino virus are all
targeted by bees in some cases and
virus is identified at the same time as
Rhino virus given their similarities
coronavirus in the case of two of these
adenovirus and then some of these also
include bacterial pathogens so for
example the bio fire includes pertussis
and para pertussis chlamydia pneumonia
and mycoplasma pneumoniae the nanosphere
are P flex includes four to tell'em you
can see the lumen X also includes a
couple of bacterial pathogens the input
for these is typically a nasopharyngeal
sample and it's worth pointing out that
particularly for patients with the lower
respiratory tract infections a
nasopharyngeal sample can sometimes lead
to a lower likelihood of recovery of the
pathogen and and that's something that's
known to impact all of these tests
that's not so much a test characteristic
but more function of the the physiology
I didn't go over the numbers for these
in terms of sensitivity and specificity
because they're very similar to what you
see with the the the smaller panels of
nucleic acid amplification tests again
they tend to be quite high generally 90%
and above now one of the limitations
with pathogen detection assays is the
question of carriage versus infection
and I alluded to this in the case of
pneumococcal pneumonia and here's one
study that highlights that this was a
study that looked at 200 children ages 3
to 7 they were all asymptomatic
they enrolled them at nine different
daycare centers and they obtained NP
swabs just to detect whether or not
these individuals had pneumococcal
carriage in their nares and then also
simultaneously assess whether or not
pneumococcal antigen was present in a
urine antigen assay well you can see
that there is to some degree a function
of age age group that had carriage was
about the four-year old age group but in
general it was around 44 to 60% had
carriage of pneumococcus in the
nasopharynx and the free
see with which these children shed
pneumococcal antigen in their urine and
habits positive assay was quite high as
high as 39% in the youngest age group
declining to 18% by the time they were 6
years old and this just really
highlights why this particular test is
infrequently used in a pediatric
population because of the high rate of
false positives
even in asymptomatic children well the
same also goes from viruses this was a
study called the Big Love study this is
one that looked to identify the presence
of viral pathogens in families in Utah
over the course of about one year and in
each of these different boxes is a
different pathogen that was targeted
they used the bio fire film array to
measure these different viruses families
were sampled longitudinally generally
getting a sample about once a week and
in each of these plots you see different
numbers on the x-axis and those numbers
correspond to the duration of shedding
in weeks and the other thing to point
out is there's in each of those
different bars there's a darker section
on the bottom and a lighter section on
the top that corresponds to whether or
not virus was detected at a time that
the patient was symptomatic and so the
darker sections so if we example if we
go to the top left the book of iris
section there were 150 one episodes in
which Boca virus was detected in this
population the majority of patients who
had Boca virus detection had it detected
for a limited period of time just one
week around the time of a respiratory
illness but of that group only about 46%
were symptomatic the remainder of those
cases had detectable Boca virus but at
times that they had no symptoms for
rhinovirus you see similarly high rates
of symptomatic and asymptomatic shedding
the same goes for adenovirus where 40%
of adenoviral detection occurred in
patients who had no symptoms and you can
see those same trends for most of these
viruses some
to be less common one of the
coronaviruses it's hard to extrapolate
it only had two cases most of the other
corona strains did have a significant
number of asymptomatic shedding among
patient cases of meta pneumo virus and
influenza you did tend to see more cases
associated with symptomatic illness than
with asymptomatic illness but even with
influenza you're seeing detection of
influenza and people who don't have
symptoms some of the parent flu ends of
viruses had almost no association with
symptoms erin-flynn 2 3 & 4 though again
the numbers for those cases are quite
small well with this really highlights
and the point I want to make is that if
you have somebody who presents and they
are sick and you do one of these
pathogen detection tests and it comes
out positive would it have would it have
come out positive even if the patient
was asymptomatic is that someone who
simply has the presence of a virus but
that is not associated with the symptoms
that they're coming in with or is that
actually the cause of their symptoms if
you're just as likely to find Rhino
virus and someone who's sick someone who
isn't sick what does it mean then when
you find Rhino virus in somebody who has
pneumonia or who has a respiratory tract
infection so this is undoubtedly one of
the challenges associated with these
pathogen detection strategies in this
slide this this is the epic study again
we had started off the presentation
talking about and this is just another
study that highlights this point in this
case they had just over a thousand
patients with community acquired
pneumonia and then 759 patients that
they identified as asymptomatic controls
and they compared the rates of
identification of different viruses in
controls versus those who had pneumonia
in the top panel is a focus on children
and what you can see is that a quarter
of children 24.4% who were asymptomatic
had a virus detected
whereas that number was 68.8% among
children with community card pneumonia
so certainly you're more likely to get a
virus identified when you're sick
then when you're not but that's still a
significant number of patients without
symptoms who have a virus detectable you
can see rhinovirus those numbers are
pretty similar 17 an asymptomatic versus
22 and pneumonia but for others for
example RSV and metapneumovirus if you
find the virus there's a pretty good bet
that that's what's causing your illness
just given in this study the low rate of
carriage in asymptomatic children in
adults the story was very different only
2% of adults out of 238 of asymptomatic
adults had a virus detected compared to
almost a quarter of adults with
community-acquired pneumonia had a viral
pathogen identified and so it's it's
much more likely that if you're an adult
and you have a viral pathogen identified
that that is likely to be the cause of
your illness just given the known low
frequency of carriage and shedding in an
asymptomatic adult population and so
given the challenges associated with
detecting pathogens and then
interpreting the results can we learn
more by looking at how the host responds
to the infection so again sometimes you
may have low sensitivity sometimes it
may be low specificity it may be a long
time to result or there may be
uncertainty as to how to interpret a
positive or negative result and those
are all problems that different pathogen
detection strategies have some have
strengths but each one of them has
certain limitations and so is it
possible to learn more by focusing on
the host now the ideal biomarker in
terms of a host biomarker to help
discriminate viral and bacterial
infection would be one that is rapid and
the time to get to a result depends a
little bit on your testing environment
if you're thinking about somewhere
downstream we're certainly not there yet
but somewhere downstream where you might
have home testing or potentially field
testing in resource-limited environments
a test that is very rapid occurring
within a few minutes is ideal in an
outpatient environment you there really
isn't time to run a test that takes
longer than 20 minutes if you're in an
ER a test that takes an hour as
tolerable and if it's a
analyze patient there are many tests
that are order that takes significantly
longer to get a result in which case
there's a little bit more tolerance for
a longer time to result but ideally it
should be as quick as possible a low
complexity test that's easy to perform
one that's inexpensive a non-invasive or
minimally invasive test something that
discriminates colonization from
infection and something that
distinguishes from non infectious
etiologies many patients who present
with with acute illness whether it's
respiratory illness or otherwise don't
have an infection at all they may be
coming in with allergic rhinitis or
allergy related symptoms they may be
coming in with heart failure with a
costochondritis with post nasal drip
acid reflux there's a very large list of
conditions that are not infectious that
can mimic the symptoms that you would
see in someone with a bacterial or a
viral infection so an ideal biomarker is
one that can also distinguish
non-infectious disease from infectious
disease well let's talk a little bit
about some of these biomarkers probably
the one that is receiving the most
attention and is available for clinical
use in the US as well as in Europe is
procalcitonin procalcitonin is a
precursor of calcitonin which most of
you may recognize as being involved in
in calcium metabolism and homeostasis
the parathyroid normally produces PCT
and converts it to calcitonin for
calcium related biology
however procalcitonin is also produced
by other cells and in particular under a
normal healthy situation levels are
quite low in the serum less than 0.05
nano grams per mil but in the context of
bacterial infection procalcitonin
production is stimulated not just in a
parathyroid but by numerous tissues in
the body to lead to very high levels and
in in the most severe illness cases such
as septic shock you can see greater than
a thousandfold increases in
procalcitonin concentrations the
kinetics of it are useful for
identifying ideologies of acute illness
and so here for example you see
some early inflammatory markers aisle
six aisle 10 TNF rising within a couple
of hours of exposure in this case these
were controlled experiments where the
the exposure to the pathogen or LPS was
given at a particular known time you see
procalcitonin levels starting to rise at
around 6 hours and peaking at about 24
hours and then they start to decline
assuming that the stimulus for their
constituents releases is gone as well
CRP Rises a little bit later you start
to see increases in that at about 12
hours peaking at about 24 to 48 hours
and then starting to decline thereafter
so PCT does tend to rise early which is
very useful after treating an infection
in this case again these were also
experimental conditions procalcitonin
rises quickly and then once the
infection is treated the decline is a
little bit slower in this case and a
half-life was estimated at just about 24
hours
so measuring procalcitonin on a daily
basis for example for hospitalized
patients to track infection is very
conducive to this particular half-life
of 28 20 2.5 hours 24 hours in order to
assess response to treatment a number of
trials have been performed in to
evaluate procalcitonin and historically
the way that most of them have been done
is to use an algorithm and this is the
algorithm that's been used and this is
specifically for respiratory tract
infection there are similar trials that
have been done for for sepsis those have
slightly different cutoff values but for
respiratory tract infections a PCT value
that is less than 0.25 this group here
is a scenario in which antibiotics are
discouraged and and there's just this
this division if the if procalcitonin
levels are very low less than 0.1
antibiotics are strongly discouraged if
it's low but still a little bit of a
higher range there's still a
recommendation not to give antibiotics
and among inpatients and if antibiotics
are withheld there's a recommendation to
repeat the procalcitonin within 6 to 24
hours because it it has been shown
sometimes false negatives can occur
particularly early in disease illness
despite the fact that procalcitonin
levels can rise fairly quickly among
outpatients there's a recommendation to
reassess or repeat testing particularly
if symptoms persist or worsen and then
antibiotic therapy should still be
considered if the clinical context
warrants it in the other group among
patients with a high profile so tonin
depending on the level of increase
antibiotics are other encouraged or
strongly encouraged and then follow-up
samples and measurements of
procalcitonin can be obtained such as
daily to help follow procalcitonin and
when those levels have fallen below a
certain level then it's been shown that
antibiotics can be safely discontinued
in this particular study design again
there have been quite a number of them
including meta analyses that have looked
at these and that was recently reviewed
in this Cochrane systematic review
published at the end of 2017 there was
also a patient level meta-analysis that
was published earlier this year in
Lancet respiratory disease I believe a
respiratory medicine but I'll highlight
some of the key findings of this
particular Cochrane review and in this
case I'll first point your attention
down to the bottom one of the main
reasons that procalcitonin is used is to
try and more prudently use antibiotics
to identify those patients who need
antibiotics and those who don't and in
studies in which the procalcitonin
algorithm was available and actually let
me take a step back I described the
algorithm but the way in which these
studies were done is that patients were
randomized to either have the
procalcitonin result and the algorithm
provided to the clinician or to have the
result the procalcitonin concentration
remain blinded and essentially the
clinicians were then available or able
to apply standard of care and so it was
it was really a determination as to
whether or not the pro calcitonin result
coupled with the algorithm made a
difference in clinical management
clinicians were free to overrule the
algorithm if they felt it appropriate
and in those rates in which the
algorithm was overruled varied from
study to study but in some cases was
quite high closed for around 40% momster
having said that going back to this
meta-analysis the antibiotic exposure in
standard care was about eight days and
in those in which procalcitonin was
available it was about two and a half
days less in terms of total antibiotic
exposure much of that comes from
patients who never had antibiotics
started in the first place but a lot of
it is also contributed by patients who
had antibiotics started but then stopped
based on low measurements or rapport or
normalization of procalcitonin now it's
fine to reduce antibiotic exposure I can
decrease antibiotic use by a hundred
percent if I take your antibiotic away
but obviously the worry is that that
patients will end up with having
treatment failures and I'll jump up here
to the treatment failure part what was
actually found is that in when when
physicians used procalcitonin and used
the algorithm there was no increase in
the rate of treatment failures and if
anything it almost looked as though
there was a lower rate of treatment
failures though it failed to reach
statistical significance but the main
thing there is to demonstrate that there
was no increase in treatment failure
that was key now highlighted by that
that the Blue Oval's then is antibiotic
related side-effects and this is the
point here is that the reduction in
antibiotic related side effects was not
trivial then decreasing antibiotic
exposure by that amount led to a
significant reduction in antibiotic
related side effects and one final point
to make is perhaps a little bit
unexpected is that if we are decreasing
antibiotic exposure it makes sense that
you might see fewer side effects but you
wouldn't necessarily expect to impact
mortality and the main reason these
studies were looking at mortality was to
make sure that decreased antibiotic use
didn't increase mortality and in fact
the opposite was observed when
procalcitonin was used an antibiotic
were used more judiciously and
appropriately mortality was actually
lower than it was in standard of care
there are a number of different
hypotheses as to why but I don't think
anyone specifically knows the reason
perhaps it's simply the the antibiotic
related side effects perhaps it's
decreased antibiotic use and the effects
that might have on on the on the
microbiome there are a number of
possibilities but but it's not quite
clear and it's also possible that some
patients had antibiotics started that
might have not had antibiotics
administered in the first place and so
there may be some contribution of that
group although looking at these numbers
that that tended not to happen very
often and so the meta-analysis that I
described and the studies that went into
it were used to support an application
to the FDA in order to expand the
indications for use for procalcitonin
and that was granted at the end of 2016
or that was discussed at the end of 2016
and then granted in the beginning of
2017 and the expanded indication for use
with respect to lower respiratory tract
infections is to aid in decision making
on antibiotic therapy for patients with
suspected or confirmed lower respiratory
tract infection defined as community
acquired pneumonia acute bronchitis and
acute exacerbation of COPD in an
inpatient setting or an emergency
department and the rationale for
highlighting inpatient or emergency
department is the recognition that
procalcitonin may not be accurate in and
of itself to be the only determinant as
to whether or not antibiotics should be
prescribed and it should really be used
in conjunction with other testing other
testing such as white count PCR assays
for pathogens radiography or input from
other clinicians so that was why the
decision was made to make this
particular recommendation now
procalcitonin I showed you can
significantly reduce antibiotics and to
do it safely but there are some
potential limitations and this is one
study that I think is very
interesting because it comes back to the
epic study which we've talked about a
couple of times and what it does is it
asks what procalcitonin concentrations
are in adults who are known to have
community of partner monia and
specifically where the etiology of the
pneumonia is is presumed to be known
based on all of the testing I described
earlier with the epic study this
particular study just to highlight they
started off with a fairly large group of
patients and ultimately whittled that
down to a subset of about 1,700 patients
for whom procalcitonin concentrations
were available the majority of those
about a thousand of them did not have a
pathogen identified and again that's the
same as the 62% we saw earlier where
despite extensive microbiological
testing no pathogen was identified but
of the groups were pathogen was
identified the focus in this study was
on those who had atypical bacterial
pathogen which was 10 percent in a
typical bacterial pathogen 4 percent and
a viral etiology which was 24 percent
and what they found is looking across
these different groups here what we're
seeing is the the the procalcitonin
concentrations in these different groups
and as you might expect for patients
with a viral infection and just as an
aside the reason procalcitonin levels
are low and viral infection is because
viral infections tend to induce
interferon as part of the immune
response to viral infection in
interferon inhibits procalcitonin
release so that's the mechanism by which
procalcitonin can differentiate
bacterial from viral etiology
what you can see here is that the viral
cases tended to have low procalcitonin
concentrations however there's quite a
significant spread you see quite a
number of patients who have
procalcitonin concentrations above 0.25
which would typically be the cut-off
beyond which antibiotics would not would
be recommended on and some patients have
considered outliers but nevertheless
have procalcitonin concentrations well
over 10 and even over 100 interestingly
the atypical
terminal group looks very similar to
those with viral infection
the average does tend to be a little bit
higher but you still see a lot of
patients with atypical bacterial
infections actually have low
procalcitonin concentrations below
points who fought more than half of them
in which case you would based on
procalcitonin alone those are patients
who would not receive antibiotic therapy
among those with typical bacterial
infections the median procalcitonin
level was 2.5 which was quite high but
nevertheless a fair number of them still
had low procalcitonin concentrations and
then what you can see here are the
distributions for the micro bacterial
and the unknown now I'll highlight that
for the unknown category the concern is
always that if you don't find the
pathogen for a patient with pneumonia is
that you know what does that mean
could it be a bacteria that you're not
finding could it be a virus could it be
something else and if you use
procalcitonin as your guide those
patients appear to be most similar to
the atypical bacterial or viral group
probably sort of an average of the two
so it may be that a lot of these cases
of pneumonia with no microbiology are in
fact viral or atypical in the sense that
it is a bacterial pathogen but not one
of the typical ones that might be
identified through conventional culture
techniques also from this same paper
I'll highlight the fact that what they
did is they went and they asked what
with the performance characteristics of
procalcitonin B if we applied the
standard cutoff point to five as well as
some of other low cut-offs point one and
point five and if we go with the
standard cutoff of 0.25 the sensitivity
of procalcitonin to discriminate
bacterial from viral infection where a
bacterial is defined as typical and
atypical you see a sensitivity and
specificity of only about 66 67 percent
that improves a little bit if you
separate bacterial typical bacterial
from other pathogens where now your
sensitivity goes up to 77 percent but
that would still end up excluding your
atypical bacteria
vd ologies of pneumonia so there's a
little bit of a disconnect between this
study and the procalcitonin algorithms
and the meta-analysis I alluded to in
the sense that calcitonin here does not
seem to be a good way of discriminating
bacterial and viral infection and yet
using procalcitonin in an algorithmic
way safely decreases antibiotic use and
potentially improves patient outcomes
and so then you just wanted to wonder
why be and again that there isn't a
clear answer but it's possible that
certainly some patients with bacterial
infections don't necessarily need
antibiotics to get over them and croak a
system may be a good biomarker to help
identify patients who need antibiotics
regardless of whether it's a bacterial
infection or not or don't need
antibiotics and again highlights the
value of the host response to infection
and over what pathogen detection
strategies may identify alone another
possible explanation is that
procalcitonin the the studies that use
those algorithms they're going to
overrule and so if a patient had a
clinical syndrome consistent picture but
Lowepro calcitonin levels those
clinicians could overrule and still give
an abaya their opee
and so in those cases a Lowepro
calcitonin didn't necessarily mean that
the patient died and that may explain
some of the discrepancy between this
study and the meta-analysis and the
precocity still procalcitonin studies I
alluded to know some of the other
limitations of procalcitonin that are
worth pointing out is that you can get
both false positives and false negatives
false positives in the case of some
oncological processes other inflammatory
conditions that you see listed here and
false negatives can be seen in localized
infection that just simply may not be
enough to release procalcitonin early in
the disease process in patients with
steroid use or an atypical bacterial
infection since we just saw and so one
study that's currently being done in
order to address this is a study called
trap el RTI this is an NIH sponsored
study with support from BM air you and
in this case
the purpose of the study is to ask
whether or not procalcitonin can
identify patients for whom antibiotics
are unnecessary and this is different
from the other studies in the sense that
in the other algorithm based studies
that I described earlier the
procalcitonin measurement came along
with an algorithm that gave
recommendations but clinicians were free
to follow them or ignore them in this
case the studies being done as a
randomized non-inferiority study
comparing placebo to azithromycin in
patients with lower respiratory tract
infection will have a low pro calcitonin
level and so in a low PCG level in this
case the there is no algorithm the
patients are simply assigned to an
antibiotic or not and the primary
outcome measure will be clinical
improvement by day five and and this
particular study design to my knowledge
hasn't been done at a at a large scale
and so this will be both first to assess
whether procalcitonin in and of itself
can safely got antibiotics offer no
benefit over placebo moving beyond
procalcitonin another peptide based host
response biomarker is a test called
immuno expert this is not available in
the US but has a c e mark in europe it's
manufactured or made by a company called
me med in israel and the way this was
developed was to start with proteomics
meaning that there were a large number
of different proteins that were measured
in patients with bacterial or viral
infection and ultimately a combination
of three was identified trail which
tends to be increased in viral infection
and lower and bacterial infection IP 10
which is elevated to a greater degree in
viral infection and then c-reactive
protein which tends to be elevated to a
greater degree in patients with
bacterial infection when you combine all
three to generate a signature what you
can see in the panel on the right is you
get pretty good discrimination between
bacterial and viral cases whereas either
biomarker alone you see some
statistically significant separation but
probably not accurate in
in order to distinguish between these
groups at a clinically relevant basis
now as it currently exists this test is
a moderate complexity test it takes
about an hour and a half to two hours to
get to an answer and again it's
currently only available through
research partnerships and the way that
the test ultimately provides an answer
is you get a score where a high score
tends to be indicated bacterial
infection the low score a viral
infection and so it's it's it doesn't
appear that this test would have the
ability to identify independently a
bacterial and viral Co infection there's
also this equivocal group in the middle
where the the research that's been done
with this particular biomarker kind of
ignores those results and only focuses
on those who have a clear bacterial or a
clear viral call so some of the
strengths are that the the numbers were
shown to be better than procalcitonin so
we would assume that all of the
advantages that procalcitonin offers
would extend to this kind of a strategy
as well and perhaps even better there is
a rapid test that's being developed but
is not available as of yet another thing
a few other things to point out
in terms of weaknesses is that there is
some incorporation bias meaning that
that cases were determined to be
bacterial or viral through an
adjudication process and that the
adjudication process incorporated
c-reactive protein and so that can be to
some bias when CRP is both used to
assign your reference standard and is
also part of the test you're evaluating
the the test itself there was some
demonstration of how it performed in
patients with non-infectious illness but
by and large it hasn't really been
evaluated in that particular population
and then indeterminate or intermediate
results that middle group which
comprised about 15% of their test
population were discarded from the
analysis and were not included in their
calculations of sensitivity and
specificity so the numbers for
sensitivity and specificity are likely
to be lower when you actually evaluate
them on
every patient that was I was tested but
nevertheless from these these values
that even when you take that into
account offers are significant
improvement over the current state of
affairs and is equivalent if not better
than procalcitonin so certainly moving
in the right direction now this this
need to and motivation to generate
bacterial versus viral discriminating
tests was one that was highlighted in an
a prize a challenge that was developed
and supported by the NIH CDC and Barda
and in this case there were ten
semi-finalists that were selected for
the first phase of competition there are
a total of three phases of competition
over spread out over a few years and as
a twenty million dollar prize that
ultimately supports these different
participants and there were a number of
different strategies some of them were
focused on detection of antimicrobial
resistance but some of them were focused
on discrimination of bacterial and viral
ideologies and I'll highlight some work
that that we did ourselves that was one
of those ten groups that were that were
selected and it was developing host gene
expression to classify viral and
bacterial infection and so this is a bit
of a departure from current approaches
because it focuses on the patient's gene
expression to help discriminate
ideologies the underlying premise is
that there are different immune
responses depending on whether or not a
patient is fighting off a bacterial
viral fungal infection parasitic
infection or no infection and we started
off this lecture focusing on pathogen
detection assays we can also measure the
immune response and knowing that there
are are unique features of the immune
response we can then extrapolate from
that and determine whether or not it is
a bacterial viral or some other pathogen
causing illness so the way that we did
this in a paper that was published now a
couple of years ago was we generated
three independent gene expression based
classifiers one of them discriminated
patients with bacterial acute
respiratory illness
versus alternatives where the
alternatives were either viral infection
or no infection
a viral signature and then a signature
that discriminated patients with
infection from those without we then
applied all three classifiers to a group
of about two hundred and seventy-three
subjects and we assumed that whatever
the problem the highest probability was
because again there are three
probabilities that of a bacterial
etiology a viral etiology or
non-infectious etiology whatever the
highest probability was that determined
the class and that's demonstrated here
our reference standard was a clinical
adjudication which is represented by the
color that dark blue purple color the
are those who were determined to be
bacterial and if the tests identified
them as having a bacterial infection it
grouped them in the lower left part of
the triangle and so if you were viral
those were grouped in the top portion of
the triangle and if the test predicted a
patient as having a non infectious
illness those were in the bottom right
portion of the triangle so bacteria
bottom left
viral top non-infectious bottom right
and what you would expect to see or hope
to see and what you do see is that the
viral cases are clustering at the top
where you would expect them to the
bacterial cases are clustering at the
bottom left and the the non-infectious
cases on the bottom right test isn't
perfect you do see some colors that are
appearing in other areas in some of
those cases we went back and and and
realized that our clinical adjudication
which is by far not perfect may very
well have been wrong given the new
information that was provided by the
patient's gene expression profile but
nevertheless this this was a promising
approach we compared this to
procalcitonin and found that if the
question was does the patient have a
viral infection or not that a gene
expression approach was was pretty much
the same as procalcitonin but if the
question was does this patient have a
bacterial infection or not that's when
we started to see improvements and in
particular if the question was does the
patient have an infection of any kind or
not that's what we saw the greatest
ability
of these gene expression signatures over
procalcitonin to make the right call
well these signatures are all well and
good but ultimately what we're trying to
do is to get to a point where we have a
test available for use and so what's
happened since then is some development
work with with one company with two
companies I'll tell you about those very
briefly one of them is with bio fire
which we mentioned earlier makes nucleic
acid amplification tests for pathogen
detection assays the test itself is
relatively simple to use results in
about 45 minutes
and can work direct from blood and these
were results that were presented at ASM
in 2017 this is a preliminary version of
a bio fire based test that measures the
patient's gene expression signature in
the top group or the viral results in
the bottom group of the bacterial
results the left panel is a box plot
that highlights patients with viral
infection versus non viral theology's
and that includes bacterial infections
as well as patients who are sick without
infection and the numbers are hard to
see but the on the top right is a ROC
curve and they're a perfect test would
give you an area under the curve of one
and a useless test a completely random
test would give you an area under the
curve 0.5 and we're seeing an area under
the curve of 0.92 which is excellent in
terms of infectious disease biomarkers
that's along the lines of what you might
see with troponin or BNP for example in
cardiovascular disease in the bottom
group you see those cases of bacterial
infection being discriminated from non
bacterial infection the non bacterial
group was comprised of viral infection
as well as non infectious to illness and
there you see an AUC 0.87 a little bit
lower than that a viral infection still
again very good compared to what's
currently available this is what that
looked like or just a random selection
of patients that were tested those with
an adjudicated viral infection or in
that leftmost group and they have high
probabilities of having a viral
infection a low
abilities a bacterial infection you see
the opposite result with the next group
in the bacterial cases and then if you
were sick without infection and healthy
controls and both ended up with low
probabilities of both viral and
bacterial infections another company
that these gene expression assays have
been developed with is Q bella q bella
is not on the market but they're
generating a test that performs direct
from blood pathogen detection assays but
their technology is conducive to
measuring patient's gene expression
signatures as well and in some very
preliminary data there was an abstract
at camp in 2017 that just looked at 18
patients and and the different
categories here or H for healthy V for
viral B for bacterial s for sirs which
is non infectious illness and you can
see that there was only one mistake made
and that was a case of a patient with
kidney stones who showed up as having a
borrowing etiology when we actually went
back and looked at that case even though
the patient ultimately had a kidney
stone
they were also reporting cold symptoms
runny nose sore throat but that was was
missed in the adjudication process and
so it's actually very likely that that
patient did have a legitimate viral
signature as well there is some work
that's going to be presented at an
upcoming conference and Ekman as well
that further describes Q Bella's
development about whose gene expression
based tests and so in conclusion acute
respiratory illness is one of the most
common problems that patients seek care
for from their providers both inpatient
and outpatient most causes most cases of
acute respiratory illness or viral and
yet the majority of those patients end
up getting antibiotics molecular
pathogen detection assays are
increasingly sensitive but a variable
and sometimes indeterminate significance
that can vary from season to season
procalcitonin has been shown to decrease
antibiotic use and lead to better
clinical outcomes newer host response
peptide based assays may improve on
procalcitonin performance and host gene
expression and as a is an entirely new
domain for infectious
diagnostics with recent technical
development that has enabled
point-of-care availability and is
certainly an area to keep an eye out for
in the coming coming years some of the
research work that I've told you about
has been done by a very large group of
individuals again this is some of the
work that I eluded to a Duke I won't go
through and name them by name but
suffice it to say that it's been a very
large collaboration not just to Duke but
at multiple different centers and and on
that from that perspective we've been
very grateful for everybody's
participation and support and so with
that I'll stop there and take questions
Thank You dr. Salik for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for let's get started with our
first question the first question asks
given the discrepancy between
procalcitonin levels and ideology of
pneumonia should this biomarker really
be used to decide whether to give
antibiotics sure so that's an excellent
question and I suppose it depends a
little bit on the perspective that one
takes if the focus is on the correlation
between procalcitonin and etiology
bacterial or viral it doesn't seem to be
a particularly great correlate
it's again better than anything that's
currently available however I think the
more relevant question is a clinical
question which is what happens to
patients when you use procalcitonin um
and that's been shown in a number of
different contexts time after time to be
able to decrease antibiotic exposure
which actually improves patient outcomes
now I don't think that
should be used in isolation of
everything else you know it's it is a
biomarker but we have to remember that
that biomarkers are not perfect they are
used to aid in the diagnosis up and so
if you have a patient who comes in with
a syndrome that is very concerning for a
bacterial pneumonia or a bacterial
infection and you have a Lowepro
calcitonin I would probably go with the
the bulk of the evidence you know if
there's a white count of 20 the patient
is hypoxic there's an infiltrate on
x-ray there's purulent sputum production
no sick contacts no rest no viral
symptoms like runny nose sore throat and
it really looks to be consistent with a
bacterial infection but the PCT is low I
would still treat that patient with
antibiotics just as much as you would if
that same patient presented with a
normal white blood cell count but
otherwise evidence of infection so I
wouldn't necessarily place more emphasis
on any one particular parameter than any
other but in scenarios where there's
uncertainty as to whether or not a
patient needs antibiotics which is often
what drives Elena a lot of antibiotic
use is this this notion of well I think
that this is probably viral but I don't
really have a way to show that and I'd
hate to be wrong so I'm gonna give
antibiotics just in case that's where a
biomarker like procalcitonin can make a
significant difference by getting rid of
antibiotics for those patients if there
really wasn't a compelling indication to
give it in the first place but now you
have something that provides confidence
in the decision to withhold antibiotics
and treat the patient using other
modalities so I think ultimately yes
procalcitonin is a biomarker that should
be utilized not indiscriminately but use
it appropriately and in the context of
other clinical information thank you for
your answer our second question asks
when do you anticipate that multi
analyst host response biomarkers will be
commercially available so we're still
probably at least a couple years away
that development is ongoing and and you
know the first step was generating the
signatures and and
our research and Duke is not the only
ones to have done that there are a
number of other groups that are working
in that domain and there are a number of
other strategies to do so the technology
to be able to measure those signatures
is the second component and as I've
shown you there are at least a couple of
examples and there certainly others that
that have the means to measure gene
expression signatures reliably and and
and quickly and I think it's just a
matter of getting those technologies
fine-tuned and then getting those
studies done and through the regulatory
hurdles that any any diagnostic any new
test for me to overcome I wouldn't I
don't want you know maybe going out on a
limb but I would say probably in two to
three years is very reasonable timeframe
to expect those sorts of tests for acute
infectious disease to be available there
are a number of other gene expression
based tests that are available for other
diseases most notably for oncology but
those are sent out tests that might not
get a result back for days or weeks in
which case it's really not useful for
infectious disease so gene expression
based tests do already exist but there
aren't any that are currently available
for infectious diseases I think those
are probably maybe two to three years
away okay thank you so much for that
information
our next question asks should all
patients with acute respiratory
infection be tested for bio viral
pathogens and if so what test is most
appropriate you know so there's a lot of
scenarios where testing is important
there's a I would say a lot of scenarios
we're testing is unnecessary and the aim
the recommendation I would give is is to
think about what you'll do with the test
result before you even order the test so
if the test results for example is one
that will tell you whether a patient has
influenza or not and based on that
answer you will either give Tamiflu or
you won't our oseltamivir or you won't
then that's an appropriate patient test
but if it's an out patient who appears
to have a cold
your advice is gonna be supportive care
acetaminophen decongestants throat
lozenges been testing long change those
recommendations if however this is a
hospitalized patient someone who's much
more ill and a respiratory and expanded
respiratory panel is probably something
that's appropriate and recommended right
now they're really only reliable
antivirals for influenza but there are
other antivirals that are in development
and and so knowing that there's a viral
pathogen present will at some point in
time have more direct relevance to
treatment but it can also tell you that
a bacterial pathogen is not present
allow a patient and particularly in the
inpatient population to come off of
antibacterials when they're not
necessary so we're all patients no but
for the right patient yes it can be an
extremely important test to perform
excellent thank you for that answer we
have time for one last question today
and this question asks are there
advances in tests for bacterial
pathogens in patients with respiratory
tract infections yeah so the testing
that I had described most of it focused
on viral pathogens and part of that is
because of where the sample is obtained
most of these tests run on a
nasopharyngeal or oropharyngeal swab and
most infections that affect the back of
the nose in the back of the throat are
viral and etiology you know there are
some exceptions to that but when we
think about lower respiratory tract
infections like pneumonia where people
are most concerned about a bacterial
etiology it's unlikely that you're gonna
find that bacterial pathogen in the back
of the throat excuse me it's more likely
to come from a lower respiratory sample
now there are tests that are being
developed that use a lower respiratory
specimen whether it's sputum or
bronchoalveolar lavage for example that
do include a much larger number of
bacterial pathogens so there are tests
that are being developed molecular
diagnostic tests focused on nucleic acid
amplification
that will target bacterial pathogens but
right now they generally aren't
available the bacterial identification
test still largely focus on culture and
then some rapid antigen tests as we've
described with group a strep as well as
the urinary antigen tests so in short no
viral pathogens have a significant head
start over bacterial testing but
hopefully that will change in the near
future I would like to once again thank
dr. Salik for his presentation I would
also like to thank lappers for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again here at laberd's goodbye